The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
STUDENT 1: We would like
to present to you PV Next
Gen, Earth-Abundant Materials.
So the reason we're
doing this project
is because there
are current limits
to the high-quality
crystalline silicon
cells that we're producing.
There's too high of an
energy cost and too high
of a carbon footprint.
So we decided to identify
likely sources of failure
for earth-abundant PV.
We focus on tin sulfide, lead
sulfide, and cuprous oxide.
So we took the approach
of subjecting these PV
cells into a climate chamber
to sort of simulate aging,
and accelerated aging, and the
effects of long-term operation
out in the field.
So for a little bit
of a background,
this is a graph that we'd
like to provide you with.
If you notice, the graph
is centered around zero,
which is crystalline silicon.
And on the x-axis,
it's kind of inverted.
So the negative's on the right.
But this graph
sort of illustrates
that where we want to
be, in our research,
is in that quadrant
within the circle.
Because that's where we have
the lowest materials extraction
costs.
And we have the highest
annual electricity potential.
So those are the
kind of technologies
that we want to be looking at.
And as you can see in the
arrowhead, cuprous oxide
and lead sulfide are
in that quadrant.
JOEL: So we've
established, we've
showed you how these kinds of
materials can be less expensive
and, potentially, produce
more electricity than silicon.
However, they haven't
had the same kinds
of decades of experience
in testing as silicon has.
So we're trying to figure
out how they could possibly
fail under actual years
of operation in the field.
First, we're going to
talk about tin sulfide.
Certainly, tin and
sulfur are both elements
with which we're very familiar.
Tin has a wide
manufacturing base.
Sulfur is part of all of our
biology, pretty easy to find.
The band gap of this material
is 1.3 electronvolts,
a little bit higher
than silicon.
But that, actually,
brings it closer
to the optimum of the
Shockley-Quiesser efficiency
limits for a
single-junction solar cell.
The maximum possible
efficiency is 32%.
However, the current record
efficiency, for tin sulfide
cells, is only 1.3%.
So that gives you
an idea of the state
of development of this field.
Often, it seems that devices
are limited by their charge
extraction.
There is an interface
between the absorber layer
and buffer layers that block
electron and hole transport.
I'm going to talk about that a
little more on the next slide.
But this interface has
been, unfortunately,
not very well
characterized to date
and is often a site of
high recombination rates
that can limit the
current extracted.
However, tin sulfide is a good
material for photovoltaics.
Because it's crystal structure
is amenable to doping.
You can add substituent
atoms and tune
the electronic
properties that way.
Also, it has a high
absorption coefficient.
So it can be made into
thin film devices.
And the device that we're
going to show you today
was made using atomic
layer deposition.
Here's that schematic
that I was mentioning.
So as in this diagram, the light
is coming in from the bottom.
Don't be alarmed.
The bottom substrate, that
things are subsequently
deposited onto, is
a glass pane that
is coated with
fluorine-doped tin oxide.
This is like indium tin oxide.
It's another transparent
conducting material.
And then, this layer here
is the tin sulfide absorber.
And you can see that
on either side of it,
there is a hole-blocking layer
and an electron-blocking layer,
which prevents
charge from flowing
in the opposite direction
that we want it to.
And then, both the absorber
and the front contact
have these metal stack
electrodes patterned onto them,
onto the same side of gold,
copper, and molybdenum.
So this is a manufacturing idea
that could make tabbing easier
and eliminate shading losses.
Because all of your electronics
contact to one side on the back
here.
However, as we'll
discuss later, it
comes with some
challenges of its own.
JOLENE: The other
material that we
investigated, for this
project, was lead sulfide.
Lead sulfide is also an
earth-abundant material.
Lead is even more
abundant than tin.
The bulk band gap
of lead sulfide
is only 0.41 eV, which
is a little bit too
low to make it a good observer
material for photovoltaics.
But if you make nanocrystals,
you can tune the band gap.
So there's confinement effects
that make it so that the band
gap can actually become larger.
So we looked at lead sulfide
quantum dot solar cells.
And in particular, we looked
at lead sulfide quantum dots
and a PCBM, which is a fullerene
derivative heterojunction,
where the lead sulfide
is a p-type material.
The PCBM is the n-type material.
And we just made a
bilayer heterojunction.
With these materials, the
major potential failure mode,
that we identified,
was oxidation
of both the lead sulfide
quantum dots and the fullerenes.
And then, there's
also possibilities
of hydrolysis of this
PCBM esther group
upon reaction with the
EVA encapsulant material.
That was something that we
thought might be a problem.
The current record efficiency
for these lead sulfide quantum
dot solar cells is only 2.1%.
Also something, more
work needs to be done
in improving that efficiency.
But a major advantage
of this material system
is that both the lead sulfide
quantum dots and the fullerenes
can be solution-processed.
So they can be spin cast
onto your substrate, which
makes the processing
cost very low,
especially compared to growing
a single crystalline wafer.
The device architecture
that we used
is, again, glass coated with
a transparent conducting oxide
electrode.
And then, there's just a bilayer
heterojunction with the two
observing materials.
And then, finally, it's a metal
contact on the opposite side.
For our case, I've shown the
band structure of the devices
that we used.
And, in particular,
I wanted to point out
that the top
electrode, in our case,
was actually aluminum because
of the band alignment.
The work function
of aluminum makes it
so that the top band
aligns well with the PCBM.
And you can get charge
extraction the way
that you want.
And, again, our devices,
the quantum dots
were tuned so that the
band gap was about 1 eV.
And these are the parameters
for the devices that we used.
STUDENT 4: All right, so what
we did is our initial plan
was to collect IV curves of
before and after encapsulation
of our solar cells, and
after a period of time
spent in the
environmental chamber.
The encapsulation that we chose,
from a variety of materials,
was EVA.
Because it's an
industry standard.
For environmental chamber, we
kept it at 85 degrees Celsius
and at 85% relative humidity
to accelerate the degradation
process.
Then, we took
photos of our cells
over a period of seven days.
Here's a schematic of
an encapsulated cell.
It's a layer of glass
followed by a layer of EVA,
then the solar cell,
another layer of EVA,
and then a TPE backsheet--
again industry standard.
For our tin sulfide,
what we did is
we actually omitted the glass
layer in our encapsulation.
Because the cell came with
glass, was made with glass.
So to make the
contact, so we did
is we applied silver paste
to attach the tabbing.
And we baked them at 45 degrees
C to evaporate the solvent.
This yielded very
delicate contacts.
So we had to encapsulate
immediately in order
to hold the contacts in place.
Unfortunately, as
Joel was mentioning
about how the two
electrodes are on the back,
during the encapsulation
process, we shorted our cell.
So we were unable
to take an IV curve.
For the lead sulfide,
initially-- as
Jolene said-- we had
aluminum contacts.
Unfortunately, when
exposed to air,
this forms a layer of
aluminum oxide, which is
nearly impossible to solder to.
So we switched the
aluminum with silver,
even though it's less than
ideal for a charge extraction.
And with these
contacts, we were only
able to achieve a contact
with a large amount of solder.
And again, we could
not encapsulate.
Because we risk breaking the
cell with these contacts.
What we decided to do, then,
was encapsulate unsoldered cells
with aluminum contacts, and
do a qualitative assessment
of the color change,
which would indicate
a reaction with the encapsulant
or with the water oxygen.
So basically, unfortunately,
despite our initial plan,
we were unable to collect IV
curves for either type of cell
after encapsulation.
DANNY: So we did a series of
cross-sectional [INAUDIBLE]
images on tin sulfide device
before and after several days
in the environmental chamber.
So on the left, you have an
image of the tin sulfide layer
before exposure to the chamber.
And we can see the columnar
structure of the tin sulfide
layer.
However, after several
days, on the right
is an image of the tin sulfide
layer having some changes,
having undergone some
changes to its structure.
This may be due to either
thermal degradation or a result
of [? cleavage ?] of the cell.
We also did a series of photos
over the course of several days
on the devices.
And we noticed that there
was some color changes
in the device.
The tin sulfide
layer has undergone,
the color of tin sulfide
layer darkened over time,
especially near the
corners of the cell,
like around this edge here.
For the photo on
the extreme right,
you may notice some
yellowish tinge.
And that is due to the lighting
the photo was taken in and not
an actual change in the cell.
So as for lead sulfide, we
did a similar series of photos
on the device.
And you notice a
similar color change
has occurred across the device.
You also notice that
at the four corners,
there are contacts there.
And these contacts have been
tarnished significantly.
So we think that the color
changes, on both devices,
may be due to, one, the
leakage of the encapsulant,
two, the reaction
with the encapsulant,
and lastly, due to
thermal degradation.
KATHERINE: So if
we're going to achieve
terawatt-scale electricity
output with solar energy,
we need new materials that
are cheap and efficient.
However, the materials
we investigated still
have a lot of work to be done
before they can achieve that.
In particular, they have
very low efficiencies.
And that's something
that absolutely
needs to be overcome.
However, we focused more on
some of the other issues,
such as the contacts.
Right now, they're still
in the research phase.
So, for example, using
aluminum as a contact is fine.
However, when moving
into commercialization,
aluminum contacts
will have to be
replaced with something else.
Or something else will
have to be deposited
on top of the aluminum.
We saw degradation of the
encapsulated cells, which
indicates that the current
encapsulant will not
work with these new materials.
In particular, we think that we
need an encapsulant that will,
does not have an acidic
degradation product.
Because that was a serious
issue with the PbS quantum dot
solar cells, with
the fullerene part
can react with acid and degrade.
So we think, we did talk
about wanting class Evb?
JOEL: PVB.
KATHERINE: PVB.
But we did not have
access to that material.
And we think that the
method that we came up
with of testing materials
in the environmental chamber
will be useful in the future.
And ideally, you could
test different encapsulants
and see how well
the IV curves stay
after the environmental testing.
So we'd like to
thank several people
for helping with our
project, in particular Andy
at Fraunhofer, who's
actually here today.
We had to go to
Fraunhofer several times
to-- we had several iterations
of getting the cells.
And then, once we put
them in the chamber,
we had to take
pictures every day.
So he was there and was
able to help us with that.
Also we'd like to thank
Darcy of the Bawendi Group
for making the PbS
quantum dot cells for us.
And also the Gordon Group for
making the tin sulfide cells.
And then, finally Professor
Buonassisi and Joe
for teaching us all the
fundamentals of the devices.
So before we go
to questions, we'd
like to pass around
the cells we had.
While people are
asking questions,
we ask that you don't take them
out of the bag or the boxes
just because some them contain
lead, which it can be harmful.
But we can pass this around
while we open for questions.
PROFESSOR: Thank you, group,
[APPLAUSE]
JOEL: David.
AUDIENCE: So why, does
FTO have a different work
function from ITO?
Or for what was the reason that
you used FTO in the consultant
itself?
JOEL: I'd like to direct
that question to Danny.
DANNY: FTO is typically much
cheaper compared to ITO.
So for research
purposes, we prefer FTO.
JOEL: Is it, light leaves
out the indium, right?
DANNY: Right.
So indium's a rare matel.
And it's very expensive
and the price is going up.
So we try not to use
indium in our TCO.
AUDIENCE: Is it the
same conductivity?
DANNY: No.
For ITO, the conductivity
is much better
but, yeah, much better than FTO.
JOEL: Still working on
the transparent oxide
side of earth-abundancy.
Different project,
though, I guess.
AUDIENCE: Can you guys go back
to the environmental chamber
pictures for, I
think, tin sulfide?
Yeah.
So, yeah, can you just
walk me through this again?
The yellow is not what my
eye should be drawn to?
JOEL: Yeah, that's a
really unfortunate side
effect of the way that
the camera was that day.
But it's, I think,
it would show up
better if we turn
down the room lights.
But there is a darkening
from Day 2 to Day 3,
and then, also, to Day 6.
But that's kind of overwhelmed
by the yellow glare.
Yeah, maybe now you can
see it a little bit better.
And we also wanted to point
out that although this happens
across the whole device,
there's particularly
more change around the edges.
So that to us says
that there's definitely
something happening here where
the atmosphere is leaking in
through the encapsulant and
reacting with the device.
Because that will
happen from the outside
in, as opposed to a reaction
with the encapsulant
itself or a thermal
process, which
would affect the whole
device uniformly.
AUDIENCE: And this was EVA?
JOEL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So, I mean, EVA's
a pretty standard encapsulant
material.
JOEL: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Do you think that
there is something like the EVA
process that you used?
Or do you think there's some
reaction between the tin
sulfide and the EVA that
caused these EVA films to not
be good encapsulants?
JOLENE: So this one,
the process that we
used to encapsulate these
were not at Fraunhofer.
These were encapsulated
in Joel's lab.
And so I think that,
and the devices,
both devices that we worked
with were kind of hard.
They aren't meant
to be encapsulated.
So I think that
part of the problem
is just the geometry of
the device and the presses
that we used and everything.
We probably just didn't
get a very good seal
around the outside.
And so in this
case in particular,
I think that it's
more likely that it's
just not a very good seal.
So we're getting some leakage
rather than the tin sulfide
is reacting with the EVA.
For the quantum dots, it's
a little bit less clear
if there's a reaction
with the EVA or not.
Because there's a
little bit, there's
both degradation
from, or color changes
from the outside that affect
particularly the outside.
And there's, also, color changes
that affect the whole device.
And so, then, it's either
the quantum dots are somehow
changing or there may
be some kind of reaction
with the encapsulant.
But when we took the SEM
images, the EDX aspect of it
was not working.
So it was difficult to do any
kind of elemental analysis
there.
AUDIENCE: And just
one other question,
in this sort of accelerated
aging process, how long
would you want to see
stability for a, say,
a 30-year or 20-year?
If you were going to
warranty this cell for me,
how long would you might say?
KATHERINE: I think, usually,
they do at least six weeks.
AUDIENCE: Six weeks?
JOEL: Yeah.
JOLENE: Yeah.
KATHERINE: And so this was,
we didn't have six weeks.
But we still
[INAUDIBLE] that said.
So.
JOLENE: More work
should be done.
AUDIENCE: So how long's
your warranty on the cell?
JOLENE: Like a day.
[LAUGHTER]
JOEL: There were
other encapsulants
available at Fraunhofer.
Notably, there's
this, a thermoplastic
and an ionomer encapsulant.
But these are both new and have
entirely proprietary chemical
composition.
So we didn't think it would
be very informative to study
for our project.
Because if we saw
something happen,
we wouldn't really be
able to hypothesize
where that came from.
But there are other
materials out there
besides the standard EVA and
the polyvinyl butyrate, the PVB
that Katherine
mentioned at the end.
Just not quite as far along.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So how would you
compare the degradation
between ITO and FTO like--
JOEL: The degradation
of ITO and FTO?
AUDIENCE: How would
you compare this?
Which one would you
pick [INAUDIBLE]?
I mean, in terms of
cost, OK. [INAUDIBLE].
In terms of technique,
it would be--
AUDIENCE: So can you
repeat the question?
JOEL: The question is if there's
a difference in the degradation
between ITO, the
indium tin oxide,
and FTO, the fluorine
doped tin oxide that we
used in our tin sulfide cells.
Yeah.
Do you know anything
about that, Danny?
DANNY: Yeah, so they normally
degrade when you expose them
to extended temperatures above
650 degrees Celsius, which
is unlikely to happen in
a normal day situation.
So there's no difference
in this [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, we didn't expose
them to 650 Celsius
in our accelerated
testing either.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the aluminum contacts.
First of all, how
did you deposit them?
JOLENE: The aluminum
contacts were thermally
evaporated onto the, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So would
it be possible just
to evaporate the [INAUDIBLE].
JOLENE: Yeah,
absolutely, absolutely.
We were working with cells
that had previously been made.
That this was not our group,
we were getting materials from,
generous donations
from another group.
And so there were cells
that had already been made,
already had aluminum
contacts on them.
And so then, it would've
been much more involved
to get other people in other
groups to do stuff for us.
So we just used the
materials that we had.
AUDIENCE: And I'm guessing
they don't see these problems
because they don't solder their
contacts, just scrub them?
JOLENE: Yeah.
All the tests for the
lead sulfide cells
are done in a glovebox,
an inner atmosphere.
And they have pins
that just come down.
AUDIENCE: Right, so
it just [INAUDIBLE].
JOLENE: Yeah.
Mm-hm?
PROFESSOR: Ashley.
AUDIENCE: I'm just curious,
more of a logistical question,
did you guys have a camera
in the environmental chamber?
Or do you have to take
them out each day?
KATHERINE: And so we would
have to turn off the chamber,
cool it down, take the
cell out, take a picture,
put the cell back in,
then turn it back on.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JOEL: So in a sense, we actually
put extra stress on them.
Because there was thermal
cycling [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So maybe a two-day
warranty [INAUDIBLE].
KATHERINE: Mm-hm.
AUDIENCE: Did you try
leaving the cells [INAUDIBLE]
in the glovebox
after you [INAUDIBLE]
go down and, then,
try to [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Can he just repeat
the question again, too?
Sorry.
KATHERINE: Yeah, so he was
asking about the contacting,
the PVS devices.
And we did have, we
had two things we did.
One was we took
them in the glovebox
and tried to scratch off
the aluminum oxide layer,
and then put silver
paste on, and then make
the contacts to that.
And that still didn't work.
And then, we also got new
devices with silver contacts
on them.
And that also didn't work.
Because it either would
stick to the device,
or it would stick
to the contact.
But it wouldn't stick
to both at once.
And they would just peel off.
JOLENE: The contacts
on those devices
are less than 50
nanometers thick.
So it, in general,
soldering to them
was going to be challenging.
STUDENT 1: We tried hard.
[LAUGHTER]
JOLENE: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Is there
any future plans
to continue with this work, with
either Bawendi or Gordon Group?
Or are they, was just
kind of included?
JOLENE: Well, I think
both of these materials
are so much still in the
trying to boost efficiency
phase that it is less important
to be able to say, to talk
about the long-term stability
than to say that they're even
viable materials to begin with.
I think that they are
interested in the results.
But, yeah.
JOEL: I mean, this is
Danny's thesis, so.
[LAUGHTER]
DANNY: All right, so
[INAUDIBLE] from Gordon's Group,
we have much more problems
much greater than whether they
can last a week or two.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: One more
question, guys.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you IV curves
for Day 1 and Day 8?
KATHERINE: Yeah, so we
weren't able to get IV curves.
Because the tin
sulfide self-shorted,
and we weren't able to make
contacts to the lead sulfide,
so.
AUDIENCE: Make
enough as to make up
for what would be the
drop in-- [INAUDIBLE].
KATHERINE: So Danny has
taken tin sulfide IV
curves before the
encapsulation, right?
DANNY: Right.
So I [INAUDIBLE]
encapsulation and they
do what you see here,
pretty decent IV curve.
But before we did
the encapsulation,
the cell shorted and
[INAUDIBLE] died.
So we couldn't-- there's no
point in doing IV curve after
the test.
KATHERINE: So we took them.
But it's just a straight line.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOEL: All right, Thanks, guys.
Let's thank our speakers again.
[APPLAUSE]
JACKSON: All right, this is
Ron, Rachel, Ben, Kirsten.
And I'm Jackson.
I'm going to introduce the
Lighting Africa project.
So the main problem behind
our project is the following.
There's about 580 million people
living off-the-grid in Africa,
and about 10 million
small businesses
operating off-grid in Africa.
And as you can imagine,
after dark, they
have a major lighting problem.
So kids need lighting for
education, for reading,
for studying, et cetera.
And then, families need it
to interact with one another.
And small businesses,
a lot of them
would like to continue
operating after dark.
And currently, what they
do is they use kerosene.
But there's many problems
with kerosene lamps.
So the first of which is that
it's a major health issue.
So burning kerosene is about,
and like, for one night,
is about smoking two
packs of cigarettes
in terms of health issues.
In addition, it's very
expensive for these families.
They can barely afford to eat.
And so buying a weekly
supply of kerosene
is extremely hard for them.
And furthermore, actually the
widespread use of kerosene,
although low per capita, is
causing a large increase in CO2
in the atmosphere.
So this brings up a
large opportunity for us.
And the World Bank
Lighting Africa project
has proposed the
following solution.
And that's solar portable
lanterns, or SPLs.
And these are small
devices, maybe this big,
that have a compact
fluorescent or an LED on them.
And they have solar
panels on top.
And you set the whole
device out during the day.
And you can bring it
in during the night
and use it to light your homes.
And these are, right now, of
a fairly small market share,
compared to the kerosene, but
are growing very substantially
with a 40% to 50%
projected annual growth.
And as you can see
from the graph,
I'm sure you guys
are aware Africa
has a huge solar resource
as a great opportunity.
So the goals for our specific
project are the following.
How will next generation
solar technologies
help bring solar PV lights
to rural sub-Saharan Africa?
So our specific project
is the following.
How we looked at the next
generation of solar, so
future technologies that are
emerging in the next six months
to 10 years, and how they're
going to specifically affect
our project.
So to do this, we looked at
a few different time frames.
We looked at the six to 12 month
time frame, the one to five
year time frame, and the
five to 10 year time frame,
and made technological
prospectus of each one,
looked at a wide gamut of
different technologies,
and selected a few that
we thought would most
positively affect our project.
And we focus on the one
to five year time frame.
Because we thought that this
would be the most important to
look at.
So to do this, we looked at
a few, a couple different
consumers.
So the first consumer
is a low cost consumer.
And this is somebody who can
barely afford to eat every day
and, really, buys kerosene,
maybe, on a week-to-week basis.
It's extremely
expensive for them.
So we need to minimize
the costs of these devices
as much as possible so that
they have a low buyback time
with compared to kerosene.
And these devices
are often integrated.
So there's a solar
panel on the device.
And you put the whole
device out during the day.
And you bring the whole
device in at night.
The second consumer we looked at
is a higher performance device.
And so this is a
consumer who, maybe,
has a little bit more money
although still very poor
relative to our standards.
And then, often these
devices are separated.
So you'll have a
separate solar panel
that goes out during the day.
And then, you'll bring either
the solar panel in or leave it
outside.
And maybe there's a
cable that connects it.
And sometimes, these
are even on the roof.
And these have a little bit
some added features that I'll
talk about in a little bit.
So to look at this, we looked
at a few different metrics.
So the first,
obviously, is cost.
And that's the most
important metric.
So we looked at dollars per watt
of all these different devices,
projected dollars per watt.
And like I said
before, minimizing cost
is the most important thing.
Because these people
need an attractive device
that will pay itself back fairly
quickly in terms of kerosene,
and will be affordable.
The second thing we looked at
is a performance, so efficiency,
basically.
So we looked at the parameter
watts per centimeter squared.
And so we need to
minimize the size
so that it can fit on a
device if it's integrated,
or minimize the size
of a solar panel
if you're going to lug
it in and out every day.
And as performance goes up, you
can get a few added features.
So one of the,
actually, big problems
that, maybe, is
surprising is there's
about 50 million off-grid mobile
phones at the current time.
So these people live off-grid.
They need a place to
charge their mobile phones.
And often, they have to
bring in to the city center,
or they use hand
cranks or something
to charge their mobile phones.
And it's expensive and
difficult for them to charge.
So adding a charging
feature, to these devices,
can be extremely helpful
and save a lot of money.
In addition is you get
higher performance devices.
You can start adding radios,
fans, and TV to improve
their quality of life.
So now, I'm going to
pass it off to Kirsten.
And she's going to talk about
our six to 12 month prospectus.
KIRSTEN: Great.
Thanks, Jackson.
So it's important to note
that the Lighting Africa
project doesn't
actually manufacture
photovoltaic devices.
That is they actually cooperate
with small companies which
are risk averse, which means
at least in the next 12 months,
they're interested in the
most established manufacturing
infrastructure.
For that reason, in the
six to 12th month range,
we've just looked at silicon.
So we've compared mono-
and polycrystalline silicon
with amorphous silicon.
Of course, as you all know,
monocrystalline silicon
has a higher
efficiency but, also,
higher price per watt peak.
It's important to note that
in the Lighting Africa project
because the lifetime
of these devices
is not limited by the
photovoltaic component,
but rather by the LED,
the CFL, the battery,
it opens up an
interesting opportunity
in that the photovoltaic
component doesn't
have to last as long as
an installation you might
put on a roof in Cambridge.
It could only, maybe, be three
to five years in lifetime.
And for that reason,
we could decrease
the cost of the encapsulation
materials, the commodity
materials, the glass,
and the backing
that would normally be required.
So amorphous silicon might
be a better opportunity
in this application.
So let's compare crystalline
amorphous for the two consumers
that Jackson mentioned
in the beginning.
For Consumer 1, who's seeking
the lowest cost option,
again, we want an
integrated module
in the solar portable lantern.
So for that reason,
amorphous silicon
doesn't have a high
enough efficiency
to integrate the
device into the SPL.
It would require 400
centimeters squared.
Because the devices
are so small,
we're limiting that to the
crystalline silicon where,
again, you're not going require
as many encapsulation materials
as you would in a roof
insulation in Cambridge.
But, still.
And then, for Consumer 2, who's
seeking higher performance
modules, you could either
use amorphous silicon,
remove the
encapsulation materials,
and have a very large area solar
cell, which you could, again,
bring in and out during the day.
Or it opens up
another opportunity
in that you could use
crystalline silicon,
encapsulate it with standard
glass aluminum frame.
And this photovoltaic
module could actually
exceed the lifetime
of the device.
That is a person could buy
a solar portable lantern,
to which would only last
three to five years,
and replace the SPL later,
replace the LED in the battery
but still use the same
photovoltaic module.
So for both consumers, low
cost and high performance
seeking consumers,
crystalline silicon
presents a better solution.
With that, I'll
pass it off to Ben,
who will talk about the one
to five year prospectus.
So.
BEN: So for the one to
five year time frame,
we looked at two different
technologies, which we've,
well, we considered
crystalline silicon
to offer kind of a
baseline for cost.
And then, we looked
at technologies
where we could achieve
a cost reduction.
We focused on micromorph
silicon thin films
and organic solar cells.
These are both kind of thin
film type technologies.
You might wonder why we didn't
include cad-tel or CIGS.
The reason is because
since they contain cadmium,
they have to be recycled
at the end of their life.
And we don't think that was
very realistic in this context.
So first, I'll talk
about micromorph silicon.
And this is a tandem thin film
cell with amorphous silicon
and microcrystalline silicon.
It's on the verge
of commercialization
within the next few years.
Cost estimates are
about $0.70 a watt.
And efficiency
estimates are about 10%.
So first, we considered
the low cost option.
How inexpensive can we make a
basic solar portable lantern?
So here, you see the
historical cost in 2010.
And then, under
various scenarios
you have the cost
estimates for 2015.
The crystalline
silicon was assumed
to be the same as it is today,
basically a dollar a watt.
Micromorph silicon was
assume to be $0.70.
And then, on the
far right, we have
kind of a really
optimistic scenario where
we've reduced cost even further
by reducing encapsulation
materials just for
this application.
And so we're down
to $0.55 a watt.
What you can see
is that the costs
are going to go down regardless
of what PV platform is used.
And micromorph silicon provides
about a 5% additional cost
decrease compared to
crystalline silicon.
And that doesn't sound
like a lot to us perhaps.
But it's not insignificant
in this context.
Next, we looked at these
high-performance options.
Because since the
cost of the device
is dominated by the
non-PV materials
for these basic devices, as
you add more PV material,
you leverage the
low cost of the PV.
So we split us up into three
different high-performance
products-- the basic, the
medium or multifunctional,
and the ultra high.
And to kind of give you an idea
of what these are capable of,
the basic might
be able to provide
about five hours of light a
day and a cellphone charge.
The medium one could
charge 20 cellphones.
So this could act as a community
sort of cellphone charging
center.
And then, the high-performance
one could even power things
like sewing machines,
TVs, things like this,
so lifestyle changes or
entrepreneurial opportunities.
So now, Rachel will
talk about organic PV.
RACHEL: OK, so the second
low cost alternative
to crystalline silicon, that we
considered in the one to five
year range, was
organic photovoltaics.
And organics are unique because
they're made up entirely
of carbon-based
plastic material, which
means that they're
manufacturing costs can actually
be substantially lower
than that of silicon.
And in fact, they're forecast
only cost $0.50 a watt by 2015.
And unfortunately,
their efficiencies
are less promising.
Because they're
only about 1% to 3%.
But Heliatek, which is
a Dresden based company,
has recently set a new
record for almost 10%
with their tandem organic cell.
So the first thing
we're going to look at
is how organic PV could play
a role in the inexpensive SPL
for the first customer.
And this is a plot of the module
area required for various power
generation capacities.
And it compares 20%
efficient silicon
with 3% and 5%
efficient organic PV.
And basically,
what this shows is
that to generate the same amount
of power as a silicon cell,
you need a substantially
larger area of organics.
Because it's so much less
efficient than the silicon.
So this affects
the first customer.
Because in order just to
generate the 2.5 watts
necessary for the
SPL, you actually
need over 800 square
centimeters of 3%
efficient organic material,
which is not reasonably
something that you
could fit onto a lantern
that you have to
carry around with you.
So because the first customer
requires a solar panel that
could be entirely integrated
onto a handheld device,
its organic PV doesn't really
represent a great option,
at least in the one
to five year term,
because it's
efficiencies are so low.
OK, so the second thing
we're going to look at
is how organic PV
might be useful
to the high-performance
modules that
are entirely separated from
the devices that they charge.
This is the second customer.
So this is a plot
of the manufacturing
cost of the entire device and
versus the power generation
capacity.
And it compares a dollar
per watt silicon with $0.50
and $0.35 per watt organic PV.
And basically, what this
shows-- this is pretty much
the same plot that Ben just
showed except it compares
organics-- is that as we look at
a more high-performance device,
the cost savings, that
you get from switching
from silicon to organics, are
actually quite substantial.
And in fact, for the same cost
as a given silicon device,
you can actually get almost
twice the power generation
capacity by switching
to organics.
So for this reason, and also
because a module area is not
really a constraint
in this context,
because we're just talking about
building a module that you're
going to leave in your
yard, and not carry around
with you on a
lantern, organic PV
is actually an excellent option
as a low cost alternative
to crystalline silicon in
the one to five year range
despite its very low efficiency.
OK, so the conclusions for
the one to five year term,
basically, are that the
manufacturing cost of the SPL
can be moderately
decreased by switching
from crystalline
silicon to micromorph.
And there are greater
cost reductions
available in the higher
performance modules.
Because as the lower costs
of micromorph and organic
PV can be more fully
leveraged as we
consider a device with greater
power generating capacity.
So with that, I will give
it to Ron for the 10-year.
RON : OK, so moving on to the
five to 10 year prospectus,
this had a unique challenge
in that, oftentimes,
research cell modules
will have a huge barrier
to commercialization.
And these are things that the
probability of them actually
realizing commercialization,
in the five to 10 year period,
decreases significantly.
So what we did is we tried to
look at modules that we're not
like thermal photovoltaics or
interband gap transition cells.
Because we were afraid that
the probability of those
actually reaching
commercialization
were very low.
So one option that
stood out to us
was actually an extension of
the one to five year period,
was the mature organics as
the benefits that both Ben
and that Rachel mentioned.
Specifically, that as the
areas of the cell get larger,
they could have a very
good cost leverage.
Because they could power
other household items
such as TV, fans, and radios.
Granted.
also they have extremely
attractive dollar
per watt peak performances
because of their extremely low
cost and moderate performances.
Also, we expect that
commercialization
will be set to begin and that,
actually, the efficiencies
of commercial scale modules
will reach 5% to 8%,
which are actually pretty
good performance modules.
Another thing that
stood out to us
was actually cadmium-free
CIGS technology.
And as Ben mentioned, cadmium
has a huge environmental impact
and would require a recycling
process, which is not practical
given this context.
So we looked at a
cadmium-free CIGS technology
that would actually have
the benefits of thin films
in their low cost and
moderate performance,
but not have the actual
environmental concerns
associated with them.
So currently, in lab, there
have been a few options
to replace the cadmium
sulfide buffer layer.
There's been zinc oxide,
and also zinc indium
selenide compounds that can,
actually, be grown epitaxially
in the manufacturing
process, making
it really easy for
roll-to-roll processing.
So currently, in the
research cell modules,
they are reaching about 10%
to 12% efficiencies, which
is really promising
given they're actually,
it hasn't been
studied for that long.
So we expect that in the
five to 10 year period,
we could actually realize this
high-efficiency cadmium-free
CIG cells, especially since
manufacturing processes have
already been developed
for the CIGS cells.
So for the long-term
conclusions,
we think that the cadmium-free
CIGS modules be great
for Consumer 1 because of
their moderate performance
and their attractive dollar
per watt peak metrics,
making them, actually,
integratable on a small area,
and providing the 2.5
watts for the SPL.
For Consumer 2, we
actually thought
a large, mature organics
module in their backyard
would be great because
of their really low cost,
and also because
of their ability
to possibly charge
other household devices
as their performance increases.
And these are, basically,
the conclusions
of all my other
colleagues in front of me.
The six to 12 month mono-
and multicrystalline
are the best options.
In the one to five year
period, micromorph and organics
will play a larger role.
And in the five to 10
year, organics and CF CIGS
stand out as very
attractive options.
So in conclusion, next
generation photovoltaic
technologies definitely have
the capability, especially as
alternatives to current
crystalline technology,
to provide a green and positive
difference in the Lighting
Africa project.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Have you
worked with anybody,
like D-Lab or any other
nonprofits that have
done this kind of work before?
Because, sometimes, it's
about the relationships
that you can build
with the companies,
the kind of discounted products
that they can give you.
And that's, sometimes,
kind of takes over.
JACKSON: Yeah, so, I guess,
we skipped this slide.
Or we didn't get to it.
But we actually worked
with the World Bank,
the Lighting Africa is
with the World Bank.
We also worked with
people who were
working on it at Humboldt
State University,
and talked a lot to them.
And right now, so one
thing that's important
is that the Lighting
Africa project
is, they provide a lot of
education and information
to companies.
But the companies
are the one that
actually build the devices.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: So it's
up to the companies
to decide which one [INAUDIBLE].
JACKSON: Exactly, yeah.
And so the Lighting Africa
provides information to them.
And our report will be provided
to the companies as well.
But in the end, it's
up to them to decide
what's most profitable.
KIRSTEN: And also,
there's several companies
that the Lighting Africa
project works with.
And each company provides a
slightly different solution.
So there's a whole spectrum of
the number of watts you have,
the number of kilowatt hours.
So there are several
different solutions based
on the different companies.
AUDIENCE: So when
[INAUDIBLE] dollar
per watt, what about thermal
degradation for all [INAUDIBLE]
that could be a
major problem, right?
I mean, like [INAUDIBLE] itself,
I mean, that's why they're not,
I think, [INAUDIBLE].
RON : So what's, actually,
really positive about this
project is that we're not
really looking for high lifetime
devices.
So it's, actually,
limited by the batteries
and by the other
components of the SPL.
So that's only, they only
have about two to three year
lifetime.
So we think that even though,
obviously, Africa's hot,
there the thermal
degradation will actually not
be the limiting
factor in this case,
especially if they're
encapsulated with relative--
AUDIENCE: So that could
increase the cost, right?
RON : No, actually
if you reduce,
since the cost is dominated
by non-PV materials,
we could actually reduce the
encapsulant costs significantly
and still have a
relatively good lifetime.
AUDIENCE: So could you
comment on that, actually,
a little bit?
What kind of lifetimes
would you expect out
of the current
production organic cells?
RON : [INAUDIBLE]
JACKSON: Yeah, Rachel.
[LAUGHTER]
RACHEL: OK, great.
So, oftentimes, you'll find that
current commercialized organic
cells only last a
couple of days actually.
Although it has been proven
that certain cells can last up
to three years, which would be
sufficient for the lifetimes
that we're looking at.
And this is also in the
one to five year range.
We're not talking about
doing this tomorrow.
So, hopefully,
that sort of metric
would be improved
within that time frame.
AUDIENCE: And you
guys have a sense
is it an encapsulation challenge
or a fundamental materials
challenge?
RACHEL: I think it's a
fundamental materials
challenge.
It's the actual--
JACKSON: Yeah, and
this actually gives
a great place for organics
because of our time frame.
Usually in the US
or, the modules last
for 20 or 30 years.
But here, the
lifetime of the device
is really two or three years.
So it's a great
opportunity for organics.
KIRSTEN: Yeah, and
then the opportunity
for decreasing module costs.
It just doesn't go all
the way across the board.
It's more important for
silicon than organics.
Because, again, organics
aren't as [INAUDIBLE].
RON : And also I know that
hydrolysis of the carbon-based
compounds is one of
the big problems.
So they're really
not good for, like,
relatively humid environments.
And in this case,
we're going to be
in the sub-Saharan
African desert.
So it's going, that
won't be an issue.
AUDIENCE: Did you, do you have
any idea about what market,
what the size of
the market would
be for different possible
costs that you outlined
on some of those line graphs?
Say your total lantern
cost is $40 or something.
How many people can buy it
if that's what the price is?
KIRSTEN: So we've, the
top 10% of the population
in sub-Saharan Africa
earns 40% of the GDP.
So there would be very few
people in the second customer
bracket.
Whereas, most people, I guess,
earn less than a dollar a day
and would be our target
for the first archetypal,
as the first
archetypal customer.
AUDIENCE: So if most of the
people earn less than a dollar
a day, are they going to save
up couple months of income
somehow in order to
buy a $30 lantern.
That's what I'm asking.
JACKSON: Yeah, so currently,
the buy back time on these
are about eight months.
So it's very significant.
And that's why there's not
widespread proliferation.
But right now, the
Lighting Africa project
is working on education.
And in areas that
they've started
these educational programs, the
proliferation of these products
have actually
increased dramatically.
And people have started saving
up for them, and buying them.
And actually, there's one of the
main problems with the project
that there's a wide
scale, there's,
like, Chinese
companies that come in.
And they'll sell very,
very cheap devices
that are extremely shoddy.
They last maybe a few
weeks or something.
And they're really cheap.
But they don't really
do too much good.
So increasing
education about those,
and the Lighting Africa project
gives certification of devices
that will last a few years.
And so increasing
education and decreasing
buy back time, which is one of
the main things we'll increase.
AUDIENCE: Sounds like
you do consumer reports.
JACKSON: Yeah.
RON : And also,
one of the, I mean,
this is actually more
towards customer too.
But one of the positive
things about this project
is that communities could pool
resources together and actually
have their household
items be charged together
in one person's house, in
the middle of the community.
Could have that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
have a question sort
of like all these lights
I'm assuming use batteries,
like the cadmium batteries
or [? lithium ?] batteries,
and so on, so forth.
And those are
hazardous materials.
And I'm sure they're either
dealing with them or they
aren't.
So given that fact, doesn't
that make your assumption
that you ruled out
cad-tel or CIGS
cells to be incorrect
in that you already
have hazardous materials
in the batteries.
JACKSON: Right.
So right now, I
think, for the most,
they are [INAUDIBLE]
in these batteries.
Most of the batteries are
fairly well sealed and such.
But I think, ethically,
we couldn't suggest
more hazardous materials.
And so you're saying that
just because there's already
a problem, why don't we
just add another one.
I don't think that's
necessarily a good option.
But you're right
about the batteries.
AUDIENCE: So for your tier one
customer, your lower income
customer, you're pretty much
only providing them lighting.
Is that correct?
Or do you think--
JACKSON: Right.
AUDIENCE: --that
there's options?
I mean, you have a lot of
graphs that had area of device
in cost, and for the
different technologies.
Do you have any
idea, if I wanted
to charge a
cellphone, where we'd
have to lie on those graphs?
RACHEL: Yeah.
It's a good question.
JACKSON: [INAUDIBLE] appendix.
KIRSTEN: Should we
skip to the appendix?
RON: Yeah, of course.
BEN: Yeah, so
charging a cellphone--
AUDIENCE: I mean, so if you
want lighting and cellphone,
how much does that
add to the cost?
BEN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there a
larger market for that?
BEN: So there could be a
very large market for that.
Because it doesn't, actually,
take that much energy.
It takes about four watt-hours
to charge a cellphone.
So for a very basic
device that maybe produces
nine watt-hours a day, you
could get five hours of light,
for instance, depending on
the efficiency of your LED,
and, then, also
charge a cellphone.
So it's actually, it's
not a great threshold
to overcome to be able to
charge other things, especially
cellphones.
JACKSON: And the non-PV
aspect of the cellphone charge
is also very cheap.
AUDIENCE: Could you
please comment again
on why you say that, or do
you see higher potential
in organics for the
one to five year period
than in cadmium-free CIGS cells?
So why did you get
to the conclusion
to recommend organics
for the one to five
and CIGS for the longer term?
RON: We wanted to
be conservative.
And cadmium-free
CIG cells have only
been recently not
discovered, but researched
in the past year or two.
So we wanted to be kind of
conservative with our estimates
and take into account
that there might
be big hurdles to
commercialization.
So we put in the five
to 10 year period.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So one of
the interesting things
about electricity generation
in Africa, it seems,
is the lack of a legacy system.
And so you really do have
this question of like,
what is the most cost effective
way of delivering power today
rather than what's the most
cost effective way of delivering
power when you have
electricity grid?
But what, do you guys
have a sense of sort
of the cost per person at
which electrification by grid
becomes a compelling
thing to do?
JACKSON: Yeah, that sounds
something we looked into.
[LAUGHTER]
JACKSON: Definitely, I think
the cost would be pretty high,
at least compared
to these devices.
I mean, of course, you
have a lot of, it's very,
very spread out, and a lot
of small villages, and what
not, which these are
targeted towards.
One of the other ideas,
one of the other concepts
that was looked at was
a larger scale version
of this where you have a
large PVA ray or a few panels
in the city or the city center.
And then, all the villagers
could come in and charge
your batteries that way.
And they all have
little [INAUDIBLE],
which was another model
that is being looked at.
AUDIENCE: So it sounds
like what you're
saying is that if you push
more towards concentrated
populations, then the
hereto kind of becomes
more favorable where
you can have larger
installations and
central locations
that communities pool
together and share.
JACKSON: Yeah, that's
where we're going.
BEN: Yeah, there's two
different demographics.
So you have your
off-grid suburban.
And then, you have
off-grid very rural.
So often, in the relatively high
income bracket, the tier two,
these are people living in kind
of off-grid suburban areas.
There just outskirts of
cities and things like that.
JACKSON: And another
thing, actually,
is that we talk
about off-grid a lot.
But the actual grid
in Africa is so poor
that these products are actually
very applicable to them.
Some people have
blackouts daily or weekly,
such that these devices
become necessary as well.
PROFESSOR: All right, let's
thank our speakers again.
[APPLAUSE]
STUDENT 1: So hi, everyone.
We are Team 6.
And we are going to talk about
the potential of simulation
softwares to predict the
photovoltaic performances.
And our team members are
[INAUDIBLE], Noami, myself,
[INAUDIBLE], and Omar, here.
OK, so this is the
figure that you guys
are very much familiar with.
So we all do know that
silicon solar cells show
the benefit of high efficiency,
whereas the efficiency
of the thin film, or
emerging photovoltaics,
are relatively low.
But they are definitely
under a spotlight.
Because they do
have the advantage
over the silicon such as
higher absorption efficient,
and lower manufacturing
costs, and the flexibility.
So we are going to simulate
based on the materials used
in these types of solar cells.
So our model, in
general, because they
do have a lot of benefits,
such as it is very much useful.
But it is impossible or
impractical to create
certain experimental conditions.
And also, [? doing ?]
assimilation
is much more efficient in
terms of money and time taken.
And also, we can do the
fundamental and simple
understanding at a very small
scale such as atomic scale.
But there's one very
critical limitation.
That is the accuracy problem.
So this means in many
cases, the accuracy matters.
Like it's not really accurate
as the [INAUDIBLE] happens.
So the system to be modeled
will be explained in detail
by following speaker.
However, if I speak,
if I say very briefly,
it can be divided into three.
First, all organic such
as P3HT and PCBM system.
And the second one is all
inorganic, such as lead
sulfide quantum dot and
titanium [? fullerene. ?]
And the last one is some
combination of those, so called
hybrid cells.
So our aims here, our first, we
are going to introduce the two
simulation packages
and, then, followed
by the comparison of the
performance by, sorry,
performance from the
simulation with the values
from the literature.
And in the detailed
study section,
we basically change everything
in the simulation package,
such as layer
thickness, temperature,
band energy levels including
the electron affinity and band
gaps, and lastly,
the carrier mobility.
And then, the presentation
will be concluded
with sensitivity studies here.
STUDENT 2: So the
question raised
as to which simulation
packages we should use.
So you all are
familiar with PC1D,
which is industry standard for
simulating crystalline silicon.
However, given that we're
simulating organic materials,
inorganic materials
at very low transport,
we opted to go with more
generic simulators called AMPS,
from Penn State
University, and SCAPS.
And I'll discuss why.
So with these organic
materials, and these thin film
materials, traps and
recombination are a huge issue.
And the question arises as
to how to model these traps.
So at the highest level
of abstraction, that most
top-level view, you can just
look at the bulk recombination
time and simulate with that,
which is the approach that's
used by PC1D.
The second level
of abstraction is
to break up your bulk
recombination times
into the different components.
And in particular,
Shockley-Read-Hawk
recombination is very
important for these materials.
So as you remember from
class, you basically
have traps between your
conduction band and valence
band.
You have [? curves ?] that
are in these two bands.
And when they recombine,
that effectively
reduces your current.
So both AMPS and
SCAPS actually allow
for simulating these
physical traps.
So you can simulate it
with-- and these traps
have different spectrums
with respect to energy.
So for example, you can have
traps that decay exponentially
from the band edges.
Or you can just have
discrete level traps
that are certain energy level.
And you can have traps that
have a Gaussian distribution.
Both AMPS and SCAPS
allow for that.
At the same time, SCAPS allows
for spatial non-uniformities
for traps.
So for example, let's
say if I have a layer,
and at the top layer,
there's a lot of traps.
But by the time, by the
bottom of the layer,
there aren't that many traps,
I can model that in SCAPS.
However in AMPS, I
only have, I can only
model a uniform distribution
of traps spatially.
So I can't have any Gaussian
distributions or anything
like that.
The second key component for
solar cells are your contacts.
For PC1D, you can only feed it
shunt resistances and series
resistances, which is nice
in that it's convenient.
But if you don't know them
or if you can't measure them
because you don't
have the cells,
then that's a hindering factor.
So therefore, it's nice
to be able to model
the physics of your contacts
by taking the barrier
height of your metal
and semiconductor,
and by looking at the
recombination velocity.
So both SCAPS and
AMPS allows for that.
And at the same time, SCAPS
also allows for modeling
with your shunt resistance
and series resistance.
So that's nice in that if
you have those measurements,
you can just do that
instead of mucking around
with the physics.
So other considerations include
the total number of flares
that you can simulate.
AMPS is actually,
has an advantage
in that you can simulate
up to 30 layers.
So if you have graded
materials, it's
a good approximation to be able
to just simulate 30 layers.
They all pretty much do same
basic set of simulations,
including simulating
under dark conditions,
under illuminated conditions,
and band calculations.
SCAPS, and at PC1D also allow
for additional measurements,
like capacitance measurements
as a function of frequency,
or as a function of voltage,
which is very nice for physics.
Other considerations include
documentation and ease of use.
AMPS probably had the
best documentation.
You had an 80-page user manual.
SCAPS was this composed of
random PowerPoint slides
that were thrown on the website.
So it's a little bit
harder to figure out.
And finally, in
terms of ease of use,
I'd say PC1D is the easiest
just because you don't really
delve into the physics.
You just type in values.
And it simulates.
Whereas, with AMPS and SCAPS, if
you get your parameters wrong,
it won't simulate, or it'll
freeze, or things like that.
So here's this brief
run through of the user,
of the interface for SCAPS.
So this is the main page
where you set your measurement
parameters like your lighting
conditions, your voltages.
And then, from there, you
can define the structure
that you're simulating.
So in this case, this is for
a p-i-n amorphous silicon
structure.
And then, you can
define the properties
for each of those layers.
So this, for example,
are the properties
for the p-type layer.
So these are basic
material properties
like your electron
mobility, your band gaps,
so on, so forth.
And on the left, you
can define your traps.
As for AMPS, it's
got a little bit more
of a minimalistic layout, which
is more pleasing to the eye.
So this is like your basic page.
And then, from there, if you
can define each of your layers.
So with that, I'll
pass it on to Naomi.
NAOMI: So for six
organic materials and six
inorganic materials, we found
all their physical properties
from literature.
So we use either
well-known properties,
or the most common properties
for these materials
for the most common
crystalline structure,
or the crystallinity that we
would use for solar cells. .
And for some
materials, it was very
hard to find certain properties,
such as the density of states,
for example.
And we had to approximate
these numbers.
And then, we used
these properties,
these basic properties to
compare the performance
from literature
versus the values
that we obtained
from AMPS and SCAPS.
So for inorganic
solar cells, we can
see that there's a
good correspondence
between literature values
and both simulation tools.
And this is likely
due to the fact
that inorganic materials
have more similar properties
to silicon than
organic materials.
And the simulation tools
were based on silicon
when they were created.
So we looked at the open-circuit
voltage, short-circuit current,
the fill factor, and the
power conversion efficiency.
But then, when we had an
organic component to the device,
we see that there are more
significant discrepancies
between literature values
and the simulations.
So for example, in this case,
we had usually an overestimation
of the performance with
SCAPS and an underestimation
with AMPS.
And we also have
to note that we're
expecting lower performance
from our simulations
than the literature.
Because usually in
literature, the values
are reported for
bulk heterojunctions.
So a mixture of
the two materials
while in the simulation,
we use only flat bilayer
heterojunctions.
So here we can see that we have
been very little fill factors
for SCAPS and very
high efficiencies.
So that's the main discrepancy.
And for organic
solar cells, we also
obtained a very high
efficiencies from SCAP
as well as open-circuit voltage,
and some very significant
underestimations from AMPS,
of the short-circuit current,
and the efficiency.
But due to the
[INAUDIBLE] use of SCAP,
AMPS was taking longer to run.
And it was more sensitive to
small changes in property.
Sometimes we would have
convergence failures.
So we decided to
look mostly at SCAPS.
And we varied some
parameter properties
to look at how these
softwares would
respond to changes in
the physical properties
[INAUDIBLE].
STUDENT 4: So this is a where
the detailed study comes.
And the first thing
we have looked at
is the temperature [INAUDIBLE].
So only a representative
figure is shown here.
So as you learned in the class,
if we increase the temperature
from 250 to 350, the efficiency
and open-circuit voltage
is the equation.
And this is kind of
expected, because decreasing.
So we can explain the reduction
of open-circuit voltage
by, yeah, so if we
increase the temperature,
the electrons gets easier to
excite to the conduction band.
So that effective band gap
is actually decreasing.
And also we didn't show the
short-circuit current data
here.
But there's a slight increase
of short-circuit current.
And this could be, also,
explained by the same thing,
like it's easier to get
excited to the conduction band.
And the second thing we have
looked at is layer thickness.
And also, here, there only
a representative figure
is showing here.
So if we increase the
thickness from 0 to 1,000
for the [INAUDIBLE],
the efficiency
and the short-circuit current
is initially going up.
And after certain point,
the efficiency, [INAUDIBLE],
is slowly going down.
And this is also expected.
Because for the
observing material,
when we first initially
increased the layer thickness,
it gets more,
initially more light.
But after certain point,
absorbing more light effect
is already saturated.
So increased layer thickness
just means the more distance
to the electrodes.
However, whereas for
the acceptor material,
there's no significant of
effect of the layer thickness
on the performances.
AUDIENCE: It's like will you
help me with this graph, which
ones are--
STUDENT 1: Question?
AUDIENCE: Are the dotted
lines the current?
STUDENT 1: Yeah, so the
solid line is efficiency.
And the dashed line is current.
AUDIENCE: And one is for
SCAPS and one is for AMPS?
STUDENT 4: No, All
the simulations
done in SCAPS actually.
STUDENT 5: So I'm going to
talk about how you change
your particle size, you
will change your band gap,
and also change your
result of the simulation.
So as you know, changing
your particle size
of the [INAUDIBLE] will change
the band gap of the material.
And this is very important
for organic solar cell.
From the table
above, you can see
when we change the lead
sulfide, lead sulfide particle
size from bulk material
to 2.4 nanometer,
you can change your band gap
from 0.4 increase to 2.1.
So we will use these numbers
into the simulation tools
to simulate the
efficiency of two system.
One is lead sulfide zinc oxide.
The other one is lead
sulfide titanium.
So you can see the white
dot on the figures.
That's mean efficiency.
The highest efficiency occur
at the band gap is around 1.5.
So that's mean the
particle size is
smaller than the bulk material.
So which just mean if
you use smaller particle
size with the
higher band gap, you
can get a higher efficiency
because two reasons.
The first is your [INAUDIBLE]
increased because your band
gap increased.
And the second is that
your [? fill ?] factor also
increased in both systems.
So how is this simulation
[INAUDIBLE] of this simulation
compared to the literature?
So we choose the lead
sulfide titanium system.
So we used the structure in
the right, above figures.
Now, there's titanium
lead sulfide.
And then, the
[INAUDIBLE] is gold.
And then, the world record
efficiency, right now,
is around 5.1%.
So the particle size
of this literature used
is five nanometer.
So find the nanometer
in our simulation.
The result is around
4% to 5%, which is,
it's very close to each other.
But our simulation result
can help the future direction
of this research regime.
Because you can see
the simulation result.
If you change the particle
size to the lower,
to the smaller particle, you can
increase the efficiency to 8%.
So that's how simulation
can helps the research.
So I would just pass to
the sensitivity part.
STUDENT 6: We also to determine
the critical parameters
to which [INAUDIBLE] that
the performance [INAUDIBLE]
we calculated sensitivity.
Sensitivities are calculated
from changes in efficiency,
[INAUDIBLE] by varying
parameters, simulation
parameters, or
material properties.
They were expressed
in terms of change,
a 1% change of efficiency in the
parameter of relative to basis
value.
So as we can say, we found
four major parameters.
And the [INAUDIBLE]
two things out,
there were no band gaps
and electron affinity,
which are well-known
material properties.
And others are [INAUDIBLE]
thickness and temperature,
which can be controlled the
[? web ?] by it's [INAUDIBLE].
So from this
sensitivity [INAUDIBLE],
we strength, I mean,
confidence of our simulations.
NAOMI: So to conclude, after
doing all these simulations,
we found that the these
simulation softwares
were useful tools to simulate
efficiency trends as opposed
to absolute values
of the performance
parameters, which remain
challenging to simulate,
especially for
organic compounds.
However, the
sensitivity analysis
was good to validate that
the most well-known material
properties seem to
have the highest
influence on the efficiency.
And we can usually also
control temperature and layer
thickness, which
we're also very, very
influent for the efficiency.
So this project was
useful to collect
a lot of material properties.
And we could potentially
create a database
of properties that could be
useful for solar research.
And this could be
included in such,
in a project such as the
Materials Project, which
incorporates lots of
databases about materials
for different applications.
And then, if you could connect
these material databases
to the simulation
tools directly,
it would be good for a
user who simply wants
to input a pair of materials.
And then, we could
get the output
as performance
parameters directly.
And finally, we want to thank
Professor Buonassisi, as well
as the research groups
from Gent University
and from Pennsylvania State
University for the use
of their simulations softwares.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: You said
you had a problem
modeling the bulk
heterojunction organics?
I mean, because it's bulk
heterojunction instead
of a bilayer.
Did you try just
modeling a single layer
with the properties that
are a mixture of materials?
NAOMI: So.
STUDENT 1: Yeah, so actually, we
tried to do bulk heterojunction
modeling as well.
But it is limited by the
simulation capabilities.
So we can define the layer.
Yeah, so you can define
several layers in here.
But we--
STUDENT 4: We can show
the software to them.
STUDENT 1: Uh-huh.
So if we want to do the
bulk heterojunction,
we could do, just put one layer
where the effected material
properties.
However, the hard
thing was, the shifts
at the band gap,
actually, the parameter.
However, you could not
define the band gap.
Because even if we
did just one layer,
it is a mixture of
two different layers.
So it's hard to
define band gaps.
So it will mess up everything.
So we couldn't.
AUDIENCE: Your
last slide made me
think of some recent publicity
from a group, Harvard, I think.
Some guy trying to use
the distributed computing
idea similar Folding@home
or [? Study at Home, ?]
wants people to download
his screensaver,
and screen thousands of
different organic materials,
I think, for photovoltaics.
NAOMI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do You know what
software they used for that?
NAOMI: Don't know.
AUDIENCE: Custom software.
AUDIENCE: Custom software?
OK.
So can you guys go back to the,
you had an array of bar charts,
at some point, when
you were comparing
the different simulation tools.